[Música]
quiero comenzar con esta fotografía
piense normalmente en un país
culturalmente gobernado por un deporte
que todos conocemos casi con
exclusividad
si esta fotografía aparece en un
periódico o en algún medio televisivo
algunas personas verán que hay
evidentemente un
actor un
protagonista
que está evidentemente uniforme
deportivo
en postura de aceleración evidentemente
ha ganado algo
algunas personas reconocerán de qué se
trata que han estado pendientes de este
deporte particular el taekwondo
otras
miraran solamente lo que estamos
diciendo anteriormente precisamente a
este personaje
y aún más habrá aquí acuciosamente
descubrirá es un chico con síndrome de
down
y estoy muy interesante en tratarlo
por eso vamos a hablar precisamente en
la historia de él y de su éxito
en la fotografía de la derecha de su
derecha usted va a apreciar a su abuelo
paterno que era médico
y asuma a su abuela materna ambos ya
fallecidos
que lo sostienen cuando le era un bebito
déjeme contarle un poquito de historia
rápidamente
cuando en la acción primero de agosto de
1977 él nació con muchos problemas y no
se los comunicaron a sus padres que era
un par de jovencitos en ese momento
prácticamente nació muerto fue
resucitado
cinco días después de su nacimiento
se les dijo que el médico especialista
más famoso pediatra en tegucigalpa
los estaba esperando para una cita media
para hablar de unas ciertas cosas que
sucedían con ellos
ellos llevaron a su hijo llegaron la
cita médica y déjenme decirle esto
frontalmente en 1977 a pesar de que los
médicos todos tiene una formación
científica
profunda y grande no había suficiente
conocimiento acerca de este síndrome
para manejarlo con más propiedades
el hecho es que el médico fue tajante y
brutal con ellos les dijo que su hijo
había nacido con síndrome de dawn les
explicó las características que él
presentaba
desde la perspectiva tipología
y les dijo adicionalmente esta fue la
parte más brutal que él tenía un 60 70
por ciento de desarrollo con relación a
un chico en ese momento pero lógicamente
es edad
normal y les digo contundentemente esto
tiene tantos problemas fisiológicos
tantos problemas
con su sistema cardiovascular y
digestivo
que estimo que su hijo le quedan cinco
días de vida
su padre ese momento
como su hijo no atinó hacer una sola
pregunta al médico
lo que hago viendo imágenes en la mirada
profunda de su padre más incrédulo que
otra cosa no podía dar crédito a lo que
le estaban diciendo
salió
del consultorio se fue a sentar a una
acera a esperar un taxi conseguir con
sus brazos
llegó
a su apartamento y con él esos brazos se
acercó al balcón miró hacia el cielo y
se hizo una pregunta
que no olvide hasta el sol de hoy
porque yo
por qué
mi hijo primogénito
creo que el tiempo se encargó de darle
la respuesta
su hijo sufrió posteriormente varias
crisis de muerte y las logró superar y
siguieron adelante
quiero hablarles cerca ahora del cambio
de etapa infantil a cómo llega a él
el año pasado después de casi 30 años de
estar entrenando y ver a toda su familia
desfilar uno tras otro en lo cual
hablaremos posteriormente
a competir con éxitos y fracasos
pero salir y salir en los medios
entrevistados y todo el glamour que
encierra la alta competencia en
cualquier nación del mundo
él los miró pacientemente hasta que el
año pasado se produjo un evento para
americanos en méxico
y su familia luchó contra los mismos
organismos deportivos para que por lo
menos lo inscribiera que ellos se iba a
encargar de buscar cómo hacer para ir no
tenían recursos en honduras todo
absolutamente limitado estructura
recursos espinal financiamiento etc
y posteriormente lo vamos a llegar
a querétaro
y méxico
llegaron y ni siquiera conocían el venir
uno está existe lo llevo equivocadamente
a otro centro y a las diez de la noche
alguien dijo pero yo creo que hay un
evento de tarde cuando entré a la
universidad y dijeron va a una pareja y
efectivamente era al día siguiente la
selección de eeuu le invitó a entrenar
con ellos por supuesto todo ese ambiente
era absolutamente impactante para él
y luego entró al día siguiente a la
competencia llegaron al nervio y el
momento que estaba en el vent yo no los
dejaron entrar la competencia es a las
nueve en punto
y piense lo que sucede hasta las nueve
en punto abrieron las puertas para que
ellos entraran en ese momento al área de
calentamiento no al área del venido no
sé si va a competir
su padre estaba preocupadísimo porque
todo deporte hasta los de fútbol hace un
reconocimiento de cancha primero
y él tenía la certeza de que su hijo ni
siquiera había visto por dentro
escenario para medio adaptarse a lo que
le iba a confrontar no tuvo esa
oportunidad
nunca había tenido un fogueo y
competencias solamente sus 30 el
entrenamiento y la belleza de haber
visto a sus hermanos menores trabajar
luchar y competir
empezó el evento y les comunican que son
los penúltimos que después de ellos eeuu
el escenario del siguiente ello quiere
hacer adiós habían estado investigando
habían visto a los chicos con este en
este espectro de competencia que se
denomina p 20 que para chicos y chicas
con retardo mental y motor
y pudieron ver a los de brasil desde
argentina no habían podido ver a la
gente de eeuu por supuesto y sobre todo
tenían certeza de que el profesor más
connotado del mundo es precisamente el
del canadá
qué pasa haciendo disertación a nivel
mundial precisamente sobre este campo
por lo tanto asumían de que la única
posibilidad que tenía era de hacer un
buen papel que honduras se estuviese
haciendo por papel
el hecho de que comenzaron y por ahí
dicen honduras habían desfilado todos
méxico-chile todos todos todos los
países
entonces se apartó de valor los dos
habían medio calentado haciendo poquito
de práctica la noche anterior habían
tenido muchos problemas técnicos le
había estado repasando una y otra vez en
el ámbito de competencia consiste en
saberse de memoria formas denominadas
ponce con las cuales se compite
y él tenía que hacer su mejor esfuerzo
tenía problemas hasta con su grito
pero un poco suave comparado lo que
tenía que hacer
por fin
una agenda nos llevó a la mano
y habían siete pistas en competencias
simultáneamente para todo el estado al
centro
y lo llevaron ahí
en el mundo de para tarde cuando los
árbitros no dirigen sino que les permite
a los coaches por aquello de la
comunicación directa con sus atletas
especiales que ellos dirigen los
comandos el árbitro se levantó le indicó
a su padre que comenzará y su padre se
aseguró de recordar el pulso que tenía
que hacer y le dijo comience en el
lenguaje por arbitraje que es en coreano
a su vástago
comenzó y sorprendentemente comenzó a
hacerlo también
absolutamente mejorando todo lo que
había estado teniendo problemas en la
noche anterior
cuando termino
la gente estaba de pie aplaudiendo
había sorprendido el mundo en ese
momento se acercó su hijo tiene que
desfilar de nuevo de regreso se acercó a
su padre y su padre viendo al público le
dijo vamos bien
y el chiquitín
se emociona un poquito más verdad y en
ese momento
apareció en la pantalla
8.43
esto fue impresionante
le voy a primero porque los atletas
especialistas de alto rendimiento de
cualquier parte del mundo que compiten
en ese momento
tiene que saber de que el promedio de
notas que hacen esos súper especialistas
la gente normal está entre 7.98 y 8.17
cuando mucho
8.43 exagerado
y su padre instrumento tuve la certeza
de que iban bien y la gente aplaudiendo
cuando salió en las pantallas
electrónicas el porcentaje en ese
momento
y le dijo a su hijo vamos bien vamos a
hacer un segundo en un punto de una
forma 72 movimientos para cinturón negro
primer dan
y envió su hijo al centro le recordé el
porsche y lo comenzó lo empecé a
ejecutar maravillosamente
y cuando terminó un vídeo espectacular
emocionado el público estaba
totalmente de pie
y lo más lindo fue ver que cuando su
padre volteó hacia atrás todas las
pistas se habían parado
los árbitros
habían suspendido la competencia de
todas las pistas y todos de pie viendo
hacia el centro donde estaban ellos
impresionante y tuvieron la corazonada
de que iba a llevar una malla para
vergara para honduras vivan felices
salieron la gente les daba la mano por
doquier muy bonito en los mexicanos
tiene esa particularidad que busca todo
apoyas entre todos para atender a la
gente de clase muy bien
muy bien ahora piense
esto es lo importante cuando salieron
fueron la revista especializada
mundo.com se les acercó y les dijo
tenemos entrevista con ustedes y le
dijeron a perfecto magnífico cuando
vieron la cara de tenido una sorpresa en
el padre pero ustedes no se dan cuenta
de que ganaron
fue
apoteósico por eso que usted es la
expresión después en la silla de la
fotografía de la izquierda y ustedes
pues bien atrás
como él está llorando contra sí mismo
para allá y le están comunicando que
gano
su padre
y creo
que nadie más tenía ideas
de que le entendiera el íntimo en el que
estaba
lo maravilloso
pero qué es esto el síndrome de dawn
rápidamente
el síndrome de down no es una enfermedad
es un accidente genético los médicos lo
conocí como trisomía 21 porque a la hora
de unirse los cromosomas actual y
femenino se producen recreaban
recreamiento en el par 21 y eso produce
una alteración
en su tipología y en su mente
en honduras en el mundo las estadísticas
hablan de un síndrome de down por cada
mil nacimientos atención porque la
estadística madura son
un poco alarmantes uno por cada 600
nacimientos y lo único que dicen
científicamente la estadística de madura
ser es que se debe que no tienen hay ley
de aborto eso me parece una muy por
respuesta y creo que merecen
investigación más seria para determinar
cuál es la incidencia con las causas de
incidencias reales pero de todas maneras
cómo logra y el mar pone un lugar
semejante alcanzar ese nivel en la
condición a la que puede este año
fue a competir ayuda saben y se
convirtió en el primer medallista joven
de la historia de honduras
en agosto
otra vez campeón panamericano imagínense
qué belleza es el único hondureño que
tiene dos panamericanos de suspensión
y en octubre de este año cuando su
familia tiene ni idea como el resto del
mundo asia europa áfrica
se complica en cambiar del mundo
[Aplausos]
el primer planeta de esta estadística
rápidamente cómo se llega a este nivel y
ahí me hace una referencia comparación
rápida
si ustedes ven la barra de la izquierda
las barras agigantadas son presentadas
por el gobierno de islandia
islandia tenía el problema de que tenía
la juventud más inclinada al alcoholismo
jovencito adolescentes piensa bien es
impresionante el nivel estadístico que
ellos tenían
hace 20 años estas estadísticas son las
barras de la izquierda
las del centro consumidor de cannabis
atrapan el nivel en toda europa y las de
la derecha las barras altas consumidores
de tabaco y otras sustancias
como hicieron bien en las barras
adjuntas en amarillo ese es el nivel de
los jóvenes actuales para aquellos que
tenemos la mentalidad cultural nuestra
de que siempre los tipos de atrás fueron
mejores eso es falso ese gobierno hizo
lo que debía y mire lo que sucedió
apenas 25 por ciento los jóvenes usan
alcohol y bien las otras barras pequeñas
que ustedes ven adyacentes en el 2016
como es un país para cambiar toda la
actitud de una juventud completita en
toda la nación pues varias cosas
interesantes número uno decidieron
establecer una ley s más severa toque de
queda para los jóvenes que no me gusta
la palabra ahora no es cierto verdad
para los jóvenes adolescentes en alta
hora de la noche no puede una
legislación más severa para la
aprobación de productos alcohólicos y
otras bebidas y otras sustancias no
digamos
y se les quiere dedicaron en vez de
estar tantos charlas que cada vez se
vuelven contra la drogas se vuelve más
las charlas cuando lee y plantear vamos
a hablar de los valores en honduras no
viene nadie a nadie le interesa eso los
objetos los los valores para todas las
personas generalmente un país como
honduras son cada vez más parecido a los
ovnis objetos voladores no identificados
a casi nadie le importa eso son
aburridas decidieron quitar sorprender
las charlas de éstas y crear un programa
en la criba extra curricular es
fantástico brutal para hacer actividad
recorrida curriculares dedicadas al
deporte de alto nivel y al arte
y esto ha sido impresionante porque
cambió la actitud de ese pueblo
qué más sucedió con con junio quiero que
vean esto y por favor tenga en su mente
las referencias que vamos a ver a
continuación observen esta de su hermana
norah es muy conocida en el ámbito del
mundo de la televisión
es
graduadas magna cum laude en esta
universidad como idea inicial es una
súper atleta fue la primera competidora
mundialista de honduras y para
adicionarle a esto
actualmente ella es madre y tiene una
condición física que ustedes las mujeres
deben aprender a seguir es la excusa de
que hacer mamá esto es olvídense y es un
ejemplo como madre de lo que algunos
otra personalidad que anda por ahí de lo
que debe ser un amor que tiene otra
visión de sí misma
su hermano carlos
llegó a competir en el 2009 en
copenhague dinamarca
grabado ingeniero industrial de esta
misma universidad y encima de eso venció
el campeón mundial militar taxi
maquinista de argelia
y todos sus bienes como pueden ver en su
ámbito siempre estuvo rodeado
precisamente del éxito de la lucha de
fracasos pero sobre todo de eso de ser
consistente con la persecución de su
objetivo si todos como su familia
decidió que la formación de ellos tenía
que tener integrado todo arte deporte y
y por supuesto resto de su formación
académica él también ganó un concurso de
canto con 300 cantantes alrededor del
país el año pasado
maravilloso y esta es su hermana aquí
hay algo que golpea el mundo entero
porque se le hace imposible que un
estudiante de medicina puede llegar a
ser campeona del mundo y no fue en un
evento abierto no oficial repitiendo
contó cuáles de las elecciones y el tocó
enfrentar y derrotar a la mejor de
méxico a la hora de bolivia la mejor de
francia y la mejor de españa que
entonces españa era mejor selección
femenina que la misma selección de corea
y eso fue maravilloso y su hermano
júnior mayor estuvo permanentemente
escuchando y viendo desfilar a sus
hermanos
este es el de la competencia
piensen hay un estudio de la universidad
de harvard que nos dice a nosotros de
que hiciera un estudio de vida entera de
personas desde su adolescencia hasta su
vez y encontraron que las personas que
llegaran a más edad
y con éxito son aquellas personas que
logramos sostener relaciones personales
consistentes verdaderas y únicas de que
cosa más bella
yo le agrego algo más si usted en esta
última fotografía es su familia y su
familia
toda la familia absolutamente están
llenas de extra visitó su hermanita
menor también están con ellos ya se ha
llevado evidencia de comunicaciones y ha
sido competidora a nivel panamericano
precisamente en puse el mismo que su
hermano y como pueden ver juniors es uno
más ahí no hubo diferencias en ese hogar
disciplina trabajo lucha educación y
sobre todo eso que tanto nos hace falta
a todos amor
tanto lo necesitamos el futuro yo le
plantea usted es el futuro tú le plantea
a todos
esa pregunta que tiene que hacerse
ustedes son protagonistas de sus vidas
hay toda clase alimentación y
permanentemente nos vimos diciendo
nosotros mismos no puedo demasiado no
tengo recursos
y el moho antonio
no te muestra
tiene importa los hnos que usted tenga
enfrente
cuando se quiere se puede
a mayores
esta es la historia de mi vida
[Aplausos]